the news has spread and the crowd starts
running
there is a suspected coveted case inside
the venue and they don't want to be
quarantined
those inside the trade fair in guangzhou
south china now have to stay everyone
will be tested
two years into the pandemic china and
its zero coveted policy are feeling the
strain
cases have been at their highest since
the days of the initial outbreak in
wuhan major cities numbering millions of
people have effectively been locked down
school children in shanghai have been
sent to quarantine camps
this video circulating on chinese social
media appears to show that even nursery
aged children are not exempt
in the southern coastal city of xiamen
just one new case means the testing
centers are already swamped
this is a city that hasn't had a case
for a very long time indeed and now
people are rushing to get tested now
china has damped down covered outbreaks
before but it's never seen them in so
many places at such scale at such pace
since the early days of the pandemic
this is a real test of china's dynamic
zero kovid policy
but if you want to understand china's
reluctance to abandon covet zero you
only need to look at hong kong
the territory has been locked away from
the world for two years but a large part
of its elderly population are still not
fully vaccinated
that's led to the highest per capita
death rate ever recorded during the
pandemic and dead bodies powered up next
to the patients still alive vaccine
coverage in the oldest people in hong
kong is much lower than these other
places and that's the reason why
when
omicron infects this group of people
unfortunately they've had a much higher
risk of dying from covid than when the
omicron waves have spread in these other
parts of the world
but the population's patience with
kovitzero is not inexhaustible
many in shanghai have been ordered to
stay home including leo jin who has no
idea how long he must remain there the
zeo policy
can this works
nah it's it's best thing but we pay a
lot of everybody in the country pay a
lot
as many countries are moving on from
covid china is still building new
quarantine centers still locking down
millions of people
and it has no easy way out
tom cheshire sky news xiaomi